- Good afternoon, everybody.
So nice to have you with us.
We have one more student joining us.
Welcome to, well welcome
to RockEDU Science Outreach
and our lab backstage program.
My name is Jeanie.
I am coming at you from
not Rockefeller university,
but my kitchen table.
So, welcome.
And I am the director of
RockEDU Science Outreach
which basically means I like find money
in places to pay people.
So, I'm so happy to bring
you here with us today.
And we're super pumped
to, introduce you
to one of our awesome scientists.
Thank you everybody.
I'll say this is one of
the most impressive classes
your pictures are great.
'Cause usually we have
students who are not
putting their cameras on,
which has no judgment
if you don't wanna use your camera.
But, thank you
it's nice to see your faces.
So I'm gonna hand it over
to our friend, Kip.
Who is a scientist
and Kip is gonna talk about their work.
It's okay, take it away.
(clears throat)
- Hi everybody.
Like she said, my name's kip.
I grew up in Atlanta, Georgia
and I've always been
interested in science.
I would try to go to like,
whatever science outreach
events were available
to me as a kid.
And then when I got to university
I studied ecology
and I got really interested in insects
and specifically ants.
So I've been working on
those for a few years
and I, a couple of years ago I moved
to New York to Rockefeller
University to study ants here.
So that's what I'll be talking to you
about today and I'm just
hoping that we can have sort of
an engaging conversation about this.
So, I'll probably ask some questions.
And if, if I ask a question
you can just feel free to
unmute yourself and answer.
Or if you have a question
for me at any time
there might be an option
for you to raise your hand
in the zoom, like a button.
And if you do that then,
I can be interrupted and you can ask it.
I heard from your teacher,
that you guys have been
recently talking about
invasive species.
And I'm just curious to
hear it from you guys.
What, what sorts
of invasive species have you
been talking about recently?
I see Juan is raising his, his hand.
- [Juan] Well, we've been doing a project
where students in our class.
Well, all of them, we
choose an invasive species.
Like I chose cane toads
and yeah, we're doing a project on it.
- Very Cool.
Is anyone else, would
anyone else like to share
what invasive species they
chose for that project?
Looks like James raised their hand.
Hi James.
- [James] Hello.
So, the
can you hear me?
- [Kip] I can hear you yeah.
- [James] Okay, so the amazing species
that I have is the gypsy moth.
- [Kip] Oh, very cool.
Yeah, so I
I was excited to hear you guys
have been talking about that.
One thing that I sometimes
like to think about is
when an invasive species moves
from where it used to live
into a new territory, you
know, what's it eating?
Is it eating different food
than it used to than it used to eat?
Whether or not food is available?
It's probably pretty important
for whether the species
can actually survive
in the new habitat.
And I wanted to, well
I don't know but I see the
polling option available.
I thought I might give you guys a poll,
in zoom but that's okay.
I just wanted to ask,
what do you guys think?
So I, I mentioned that I study ants.
I'm curious.
What do you guys think ants eat?
I see Grayson.
Grayson would you like to answer?
- [Grayson] I think ants eat plants
and other things they find on the ground.
- [Kip] That's a really good answer.
Does anyone- maybe there's
somebody else who has,
another answer?
I might mispronounce this name Jounicka.
- [Jounicka] It's Jounicka.
- [Kip] Jounicka, sorry about that.
- [Jounicka] But I think they
eat kind of like what humans
eat cause they sometimes
take the humans food,
like stuff like bread and potatoes.
The like normally would
just humans would eat
and also plants.
- [Kip] Awesome.
Both really good answers.
And, and both frankly, correct.
Ants eat all kinds of things.
And it really just depends on what species
you're talking about
and where you find them.
So like you guys said,
especially if you find them
in an area where there's
lots of humans around,
they will probably eat things
that humans drop on the ground.
I get asked a lot.
The following question which I always find
a little bit funny.
And that's, what's the difference
between the red ants that I see
and the black pants that I see.
And so it seems like to me
a lot of people, when
they think about ants.
They have two categories in their minds.
Red ants and black ants.
In fact,
we ant biologists know ants
are incredibly diverse.
There are more than
10,000 different species
that we've identified
and there's probably many more.
And they, they eat a
variety of different things.
Some of them are strict vegetarians.
Some of them are strict
carnivores and hunt their food.
Some of them actually will will
basically farm other insects
and exclusively eat,
eat what they provide.
But the thing that all ants
basically have in common,
is that they live in colonies.
So they live in close
proximity with one another,
usually family groups
and they interact with
each other extensively.
There's lots of communication going on.
I'm curious.
How do you guys think ants
communicate with each other?
So as humans, we talk with one another.
Grayson, I see your hand there.
- [Grayson] They use their antennas,
like how bees use their in antennas.
- [Kip] Nice, yeah.
That is true.
The antennae are involved.
There was a,
Giovanni.
I probably mispronounced that,
but I saw your hand raised.
- [Giovanni] Yes It's Giovanni.
- [Kip] Giovanni, I'm so sorry.
It's okay.
I agree with Grayson.
They like connect or talk
with their antennas.
- [Kip] Cool.
So their antennae are intimately involved.
I'm just going to tell you that a lot
of what they're doing, is
something that some members
of the lab here recently learned is
that a lot of what
they're doing is smelling.
There's a little bit of tasting involved.
But a lot of it involves smelling,
chemical components called pheromones
that the ants release themselves.
And I wanted to show you an example
of anti social behavior in the colonies
and ant communication via chemicals,
that a member of our lab
who's recently graduated
has studied.
Are you guys able to see this picture
that I'm supposed to be sharing?
Cool.
I see some thumbs up.
So this is a right now it's a still image
but I'm going to show you a video.
And can you see my
mouse as well, actually,
by any chance.
So right here, this is an ant
and these are a bunch of other ants.
And all these ants are basically sisters
and they live in a colony together.
This is sort of their, their nest area.
This is a arena that they're
allowed to walk around in.
And this is a tunnel between the two.
And this is a setup that
I'll show you in a minute
that Vikrum Chandra a
former student in the lab,
constructed.
And what he wanted to study was
how these ants get their food, basically.
So the ants we study in the
lab, they exclusively eat
the brood of other ants.
So that's what this is right here.
It's an immature,
ant
that we've dyed blue
with food coloring so that
you can see it in this video.
And, we're going to
watch how these ants find
and how they collect their food.
So you can see, she can just
kind of exploring the arena.
She hasn't found it yet.
There you go.
What do you guys think
she's doing with the food?
You can just unmute yourself I think.
- [Speaker 2] I think
she's trying to take it
to her sisters.
- Yeah, Maybe, maybe.
- [Speaker 3] I just think
she is trying to eat it.
- Yeah, maybe.
What's she doing now?
- [Speaker 2] Oh, wait.
She's gonna show her sisters there's food
and so that they can help carry it.
- [Kip] Yeah. It looks
like that's what she did.
- [Speaker 3] I think she
signaled them to come over.
- [Kip] Oh man.
How do you think that she did that?
(Student answering)
- [Kip] Oh yeah.
It looks like it.
So you can sort of see
they've all sort of aggregated
on the piece of food.
And then you've got some sort
of running back to the nest
or checking things out.
Yeah, all great answers.
So
one,
the thing that I wanted
to highlight was how,
did you guys notice anything different
about when the first ant was going
to the food and when the
other ants went to the food?
Juanez I saw your hand.
- [Juanez] So I think
the difference is that,
I have two answers.
So one of the differences
is that, the ant.
They weren't, with one
ant they weren't um.
Well that ant wasn't really eating it.
I thought it was going to eat it
but then and all the other ants
and not one ant
they all came together and they started
I think they were eating it.
- [Kip] So what I would
just want to replay,
is first we're going to sort of watch
in this fast motion the path
that the first ant took
when it left the nest.
It sort of takes this roundabout route.
It doesn't really know where the food is.
It finds the food
and then it goes kind
of in a squiggly line
but more or less
it doesn't go directly back
to the nest, but it finds
it finds its way back.
And my question to you is
does that look similar to the route
that it's sisters took when
they went and found the food?
They don't run straight
to the food either.
They sort of follow the
path that she took back.
Does anyone have an idea
of why and how they took
the same path that she took?
- [Speaker 4] I think
it's their sense of smell.
- [Kip] Okay, so what do
you think they're smelling?
- [Speaker 4] The, the
sister who killed it,
what went in that path so
they will go on that path
to eat it.
- That's absolutely right.
So,
they when, when she's coming back
you mean we can't see it because,
because we're not looking
at the right angle, but she's
actually dabbing her abdomen
against the ground as she walks.
And she's laying down
little bits of pheromone
that then are, the ants can
smell on the ground as they,
as they are leaving the nest.
The other question I had is
let's just watch her walk
into the nest again.
How do you think she told her nest mates
that there was food to be had?
Like, what do you, what, how
do you think she alerted them?
Ginnicah.
- [Ginnicah] I think she alerted them
by using the little um,
ant thingies.
- [Kip] Her antennae?
- [Ginnicah] Yeah.
- [Kip] That's very close.
And so actually they, they
actually smelled what she,
how she alerted them
using- their antennae.
But we're not sure where it comes from
but somehow she released
some kind of pheromone
into the air that they were able to smell.
I'll share this video with
you guys so that you can,
look at it more if you'd like.
But for now I'd like to sort of,
show you more around the lab.
And I'll just briefly
show you the type of arena
that we use to film that video.
So this is the unit that was
filmed in, or it's one of them.
And so this is where the nest area was.
This is where the forging arena was.
It's sort of falling apart in my hands
but these are little areas
over here that we, we keep open
so that we can water the
plaster that's underneath.
So basically they're
walking around on a plaster,
which is something you might
find in like a wall somewhere.
And we keep that wet.
So it's sort of similar to soil
that the answer used to walk in on.
To allow them to, you
know, feel comfortable
and be able to survive
in their environment.
And I'll just show you briefly
how this can be taken apart.
Basically Vic Rum, he
used like a laser cutter
to cut this plastic in this
way that this was used.
And basically it comes apart
just with these screens
and you can sort of, if I can unscrew it.
You can sort of see,
how it was assembled.
And basically there's this top layer
that we can remove.
The second layer that has this mold here.
Then there's a layer that's just plaster
and it's sort of beaten up there
but, that's what they're walking on.
And then another layer underneath.
And I'd also like to
show you sort of where,
where we filmed that video.
And for that, I'm going to
take you guys around the lab.
This, this is the lab where
we do a lot of this work.
Let's see.
Got some ant pictures on the
walls that we're passing.
There's another one, the
closeup picture of an ant.
So the, the room that
I'm about to walk into,
it's probably in reverse for you.
I'm not sure, but it says
USDA containment facility.
The ants that we study they're
actually invasive species.
Not they're not invasive here yet.
But they potentially could
become invasive here.
So we have to keep them under strict
containment quarantine
control, so they don't get out.
And we're going to walk
into a climate room.
So this, this room is
maybe able to hear some
of it it's temperature
and humidity controlled
so that the ants like how it feels.
And I'm just going to show you,
this is these are,
cameras right here
that are pointing down at this
nest that I laid down there.
That's the,
the little nest that I
just took apart for you.
And these are a bunch of
cameras just to sort of show you
how, how this is set up.
We have to get the lighting right,
So there's these strips of
led lights along the wall.
And that's sort of how
that video was taken.
While, I'm in this room,
I'll also show you.
These are just little Tupperware boxes
that we keep colonies of ants inside.
And I'll go ahead and try to,
open one up for you.
It's it's like very similar Tupperware
to what you might keep leftover food in.
But we put plaster in the bottom
and then we put ants inside of it.
So, I don't know how much you can see.
But all those little Brown dots are ants
and the white, or the
lighter colored things
that they're walking on top of
those are their larvae, their babies.
And then over here is their food.
So ants on top of babies
crawling around, food
and then plaster floor.
Pretty fun.
- What kind of food is in there?
- So we, the food that we
feed them is basically,
it's all the larvae and PB of other ants.
So they eat other ants basically.
- Can we take some questions?
- Oh, absolutely yeah, please.
- So, I think we have, I am gonna,
James it would be great if
you can ask your question.
- [James] Okay, my question is about.
Okay, so my question is like
did you just like find
them and pick them up
or did you have to like buy them
and then, just like buy them?
- Okay, Yeah.
So the, the ants that we study in the lab.
We basically found, in
the field somewhere.
So, the professor who runs
this lab collected these ants.
Well this colony,
it come from San claw in the Caribbean.
And I went in the Caribbean
and he brought it here to
the States just to study.
And he had to get
special permits to do so.
Cause like I said, this was a
potentially invasive species.
And then there, the food, as I mentioned
it's also some of that we'd
go down to Georgia and collect
and then some of it we, you can buy
because in certain places
ant larvae are considered
a food that people can eat.
And so you can buy them in large
quantities for that reason.
- Wow can we take another question?
- Absolutely, and as we're doing it
I'm going to sort of walk to another area,
but go ahead and ask please.
- Hi Javonee.
Please, feel free to ask
your question or not.
I am sorry if I pronounced
your name incorrect.
- [Javonee] Yeah it's Javonee.
And, my question is
when you take the ants
from where ever they were from,
do you give them back when
they, when they're enough?
- [Kip] The, the unfortunate answer is no,
we do not, we do not
take them back usually.
The, the ones that we
study in the lab here,
we've we basically maintained
them in the lab since,
since we've had them.
There are some cases when, when
in the past I've taken ants
and when I'm done doing what
I want to do, put them back.
But I think more typically we, we don't.
- Can we also take one another question
before moving on to the
next segment from Alvierys?
Absolutely.
- [Alvierys] When the ants lay
eggs, how big are the eggs?
How many do they lay at a time?
- [Kip] That's a, that's
a really good question.
Sorry, you asked how big are they
And how many do they lay?
- [Alvierys] Yes.
- [Kip] So I'll show you
something pertaining to this.
You'll be able to see the eggs in a second
because we're going to
look at some ants under
the microscope.
But usually in, in our case,
each ant probably lays one or two eggs,
four, or maybe three I'm not
sure per egg-laying time.
So basically they about once
a month they'll lay eggs
and some, probably each ant lays one
or two eggs per month in our case.
But in some species of ants
that have ant Queens, which
you may have heard of sort of
like Queens of bee colonies,
ants also have those.
The answer to this question can
be like dramatically larger.
So in the case of army
ants, the queen is enormous.
You can be like this big
and she is actually pumping
out several eggs per second.
So like as many as like
seven eggs per second,
she can be laying.
She's basically an egg assembly line.
- Wow.
- Maybe I can show you a
picture of those in a second.
- All right.
One last question from Juanes.
And then what we'll,
we'll give you the floor.
There are just a lot
of questions coming in.
- [Kip] That's great.
- [Juanes] All right.
So have you ever seen like one or the,
how do ants act when they're like sad?
- It's hard to know
whether the ants are sad
because, well I don't speak
their chemical language
you know.
But, what I will say is that some ants,
yeah, Maybe they're just
loitering around the nest
not doing very much.
And so, ants can vary in how,
in how active they are basically.
But that doesn't necessarily
mean they're sad of course.
They can be very happy
to be not doing anything.
(laughing)
But, yeah.
So I'm not really sure the
answer to that question.
That's a good one though.
I'm briefly just going to go and grab,
some ant nests and we're
going to look at them under
the microscope.
And I'm happy to send
more questions throughout
but I thought it might be fun
to look at some ants live.
- That sounds amazing.
Ants are so beautiful
under the microscope.
Has anybody ever seen them
under the microscope before?
Yeah, Okay.
So this might be one of the first times.
And so I'm gonna call on
another person for question.
Dakarai?
- [Dakarai] It's Dakarai.
- Dakarai, thankyou.
- [Dakarai] And I have a question.
Have you ever came in
close, close encounter
with the queen bee?
I mean, not a queen bee a queen ant.
- All the time.
I used to, specifically
study the Queens and
and what they did
basically in, in fire ants
which are a big invasive species
of ants in the American Southeast.
So in Georgia, where I'm from those are,
hard to, hard to walk two feet
without running into a call.
You're stepping into a
calling and getting scuttled
but I was studying the
Queens of that species
and they do indeed look very
different from the workers.
Maybe I can show you a
picture in a little bit.
I'm going to try to..
- Alright, Addison.
Go ahead and ask your question.
- [Addison] How can
you tell the difference
between the queen bee?
I mean the queen ant and the other ants.
- [Kip] That's a great question.
I'm going to run and just grab a picture
that will very quickly
demonstrate that answer.
- Awesome, awesome.
They have a lot of really cool images
and pictures in their lab.
And we're going to have a whole
bunch of videos and pictures
from their lab on our
website that we'll make sure
that your teacher gets a link for,
so that you can check it out.
It's really, really cool.
Let's see.
I guess Juanes, if you
want to ask your question,
I think Kip has ear pods on,
so Kip will be able to hear you.
- [Kip] Yeah I'm still
listening, so go ahead.
- Great.
- [Juanes] So my question is,
can you tell us some, three
Ali's three interesting facts
about ants we might not know?
(laughing)
- [Kip] Absolutely.
- Is that a question From your homework?
- [Juanes] No.
- [Kip] That sounds
directly from the worksheet.
So, this is a picture of an ant queen.
That's the queen
and that's the worker.
So, it's pretty easy to tell
just by looking at them.
And this is a very extreme case.
So you can actually see
the white stuff like that.
That's her body.
It's just so full face
for egg-laying machinery gets so big
and you can even see right here
that's a pile of eggs coming
out of the tip of her abdomen.
Her egg-laying machinery basically becomes
so highly developed that her body is like,
severely extending to accommodate it.
In most ant species,
It's a little bit less extreme looking
but you can still tell the difference
because their body parts look different.
So, basically the queen will
typically have a larger abdomen
as, as compared with its head size.
And then also her thorax, the middle part
of her body is more, it, they
basically look different.
I- please keep asking
questions just while we do
I'm going to try to set us up
to look at these ants under
the microscope.
- Cool, all right Amari.
- [Kip] Yeah, this is, this is right here.
A picture of ants, under the microscope.
And I'll try to get this set up.
Good.
Go ahead and ask the question.
- Yeah go ahead Amari.
- [Amari] Well I have to ask that,
does ant die while they are laying eggs?
- [Kip] Ant died while laying eggs?
It depends.
Sometimes, sometimes the egg would survive
and sometimes it might not.
I'll try to see if I can zoom
in to where you guys can
actually see these eggs.
So these answer on top of,
a combination of eggs
and Pupi which are basically little,
it's like the cocoon stage of a
of a moth or a butterfly.
Right here, these things right here.
These are eggs of these ants.
These as well, and the
the black, the Brown ants are
walking on top of the white
or sort of clear looking eggs right here.
- All right Jounicka ask your question.
- [Jounicka] What happens
if the queen ant dies?
- [Kip] Oh, wonderful question.
When the queen ant dies,
typically she's the main
reproducer in the colony.
She's the main egg layer.
So the colony will usually die,
unless a new queen can enter the colony
and become the new queen.
But otherwise they might die
or sometimes both fuse
with another colony,
depending on the species.
All right James, do you have a question?
- [James] So my question is
that, what would it have happen
Do you have like a live image
or anything of like a queen bee?
I mean, not actually a
queen bee, a queen ant.
- [Kip] Unfortunately we don't
have any queen ants in the
lab so I can't do that right now,
but I could at some
point send you a teacher,
a video of that.
- Thank you, that would be great.
- [Kip] This is fun.
So here you can see little baby larvae.
So, We're under the microscope here.
That's what this, this sort
of, it looks like an egg
but you can see it's
sort of moving around.
It's moving its head around.
That's like a little baby
begging for food basically.
And she is interacting with it.
(laughing)
- All right Amari, go ahead
and ask your question.
- [Amari] Is the queen ant
the protector of regular ants?
- [Kip] Very good question.
And the answer is emphatically No.
Well, most of the time
she is basically just,
she's basically just a reproducer,
which means that in a typical ant colony
she is the mother of all of the
the ants in the colony.
But it's really her daughters
the workers that protect
her most of the time.
Usually when the colony
is starting up, though
she might be involved
in protecting her young.
But once the colony
has become established,
she is more involved in just laying eggs
and they are involved in feeding the young
and grabbing the food and protecting her.
- Okay how about Alvierys?
- [Alvierys] I have two questions.
One question is, are there any boys,
boys,
boy ants?
- [Kip] The answer is yes.
They don't play much of a role
in the life of the colony.
They basically are only involved in mating
and then they don't
they don't really play a
role in the colony life.
So I don't have any right now, but there
you can tell them apart
because they have wings
and then they have a tiny little heads.
Maybe I can send a picture of those too.
- [Alvierys] Another question
is why did you choose to study
ants?
- That's a great question.
Well, it's because,
like I mentioned before,
all ants live in colonies.
And that's just always
been fascinating to me.
They're always involved
in, in behaviors together.
They, the life cycle of a colony is,
is so much more complex
than the life cycle of an organism,
a single individual basically.
And ants are a great place
to study how that works
and,
how it evolved basically.
- All right how about Javonee?
- [Javonee] How did the queen bee get big?
- That's a good question.
So.
Let me, let me think
about this for a second.
There are, sort of two
answers to that question.
One of them is basically
that it's, it's what she
it's what she, it has to do
with what the environment was
like when she was being raised.
So basically she sort of received
more nutrition basically.
And so she was able to get
bigger because of that.
And the other answer to that is sort of
why do large individuals become Queens?
And the answer is basically that in ants,
if any individual reaches large body size
they will also have the
capacity to lay lots of eggs.
Whereas if they are at large,
that small body size, they
they don't.
They have much more limited
capacity to lay eggs.
- Okay, Dekarai.
- [Dekarai] My question is
where are the queen ants
originally from?
- [Kip] Originally from.
I'm not sure.
What do you mean exactly?
- [Dekarai] I mean like
Where were they born?
- Where were they were born.
They are born in the same colonies that,
the worker ants are born in.
It's just that some individuals,
depending on maybe the time of year
or this is the part of the nest
or the time of day, they
were late or something.
Some individuals get
to eat more than others
or higher quality food than others.
- All right.
So how about,
here's William?
Why don't you join us for a question.
- [William] Before you said where you
get ants were from the fields
but you said you have
many different species.
Were they all bunched together
or did you get them separate?
- [Kip] Yeah, they live,
they all live in yeah,
typically a single ant
colony that you find,
will only have one species
and you can find lots of
different species of ants.
I would imagine if you
guys went outside right now
and started looking for ants,
you would find several different
species, pretty quickly.
The different species
will often live, live
in different types of nests.
But they can all be in
the same single location
that you're looking on.
Does that sort of answer your question?
- [William] Yes it does.
- [Kip] And well also the,
the ants that we study
that will be like very much, they are,
I mentioned that they are
invasive, they're native
to Bangladesh, but
they're found everywhere
in the world that is tropical.
They're not found anywhere
that's more temperate
like the United States or anything.
At least not naturally, we haven't here
but we brought him here.
And we think that's
because they basically can.
They like it warm
and they can't stand
the cold temperatures.
- Justice, please go ahead
and ask your question.
- [Justice] Can ants get sick?
- Absolutely they can.
And they do.
So,
I'll just show you.
It's pretty sad.
But,
I think there was
a dead, dead ant in one of these colonies.
Yeah there's dead ants in this one.
So this colony has several
ants that got sick and died.
You can see one of them
right here i think.
That right there, is currently a dead ant.
So presumably they got sick beforehand.
There are a few ways that can happen.
It can have an infection like with a virus
or with bacteria or
commonly in the lab, fungus.
It can also starve which we
try to avoid at all costs
because we like to keep
these things alive.
But yeah.
And, and then you, you can
you might imagine in, in the COVID year
that ant colonies are
a place where it's hard
to socially distance
and they in fact, they don't basically.
So if one ant gets sick, it's
very likely that other members
of the colony, they
might get sick as well.
- Okay, we have a few minutes left,
but Jayden it would be super great.
If you could ask your question.
I'm not sure.
Maybe Jayden doesn't, okay.
I think Jayden might've
lowered their hands.
So how about..
- There was a question in the chat too.
- Okay.
- If I can...
- Yeah go ahead.
- Oh, sorry.
She asked if I can memorize
every species of ants.
I probably could if I wanted to,
but I've never tried.
The nice thing though is
that you can sort of break
them down into groups.
So for instance, the
the ants that we study are
close relatives of army ants.
So I can sort of mentally
categorize them into that group
and then think about them that way.
So I have a shorthand way of memorizing,
useful groups of ants.
- So Jayden is having
technical difficulties
but will type their question in,
but in the meantime can
we hear from Juanes?
- [Juanes] So my question is
what is the scientific name
of a fire ant?
And I think it was called.
- [Kip] Yeah, so fire ants are in the
I'm going to type it in the chat.
Fire ants are in the genus
Solenopsis.
And the name of the
species that's invasive
in the American Southeast
is full Solenopsis Invicta.
And then there are other ants that are
are there other fire ants
that are actually native
to Southern US.
And one of the species
that I actually have studied previously,
is called Solenopsis Geminata.
- Oh, just while I'm naming names,
the ants that we study in the lab,
are called clonal greater ants
and their scientific name is,
Ooceraea Biroi.
That's just for fun.
- That's a very fun name.
I think the class has to leave at 2:00 PM,
so that gives us two minutes.
And maybe we can take Jayden's question.
What inspired you to study ants?
- [Kip ] Well, that's a great question.
So I,
I basically was interested
in ecology for a long time
and I was studying abroad in Costa Rica.
Which is a very tropical area.
And there's a type of ant
that lives there called
a leaf cutter.
And I encourage you guys to look them up
if you're interested.
But basically what they do,
is they will cut little bits
off of leaves
and they will carry them in
lines that look like highways,
from the plant they're carrying
it from back to their nest.
And basically I was walking
around and I just realized
that I was crossing an ant highway
with all these ants carrying
leaves on their backs.
And I, I leaned down to look at them.
And then I noticed that on the leaves
there were little bitty ants.
Well on the leaves they
were just like half the size
or even the third of the
size of their sisters.
Maybe I can find a picture
of this to send also.
But she, the little ant riding the leaf,
was cleaning the leaf
while it was being carried.
And I just found this fascinating cause
that that's what inspired
me to study ants.
And I haven't been able
to, to kick the habit yet.
- Sounds amazing.
Ms. Dorothy, I think, is there
a way that we can maybe make sure
that everybody gets an opportunity
to get some questions answered?
Could we potentially
have them written down
and maybe we can get
back with the pictures
and a couple of answers here and there
is that something that would be helpful?
- [Ms. Dorothy] Yeah great.
I can compile them and send them to you
if you guys are cool with that.
- Kip, not that I want to make more work,
for maybe each person in your lab can
can maybe take a question
and send an answer back if that's okay.
Cause I love how engaged
and how passionate you all
are about asking questions.
And that's really what
science is all about
is asking questions.
So you're participating as
as many scientists right now
by talking about this research.
So thank you so much.
Kip, thank you for your time.
Your work is super
fascinating and I'm so glad
that we were able to showcase that
to our lovely scholars on
the other end of our zoom.
And I hope one day you'll get to come
to Rockefeller university
and either to visit
or to become a scientist
because that's where scientists study.
It's a great place come.
Yeah.
Any, any other final
thoughts that we should share
Ms. Dorothy or Kip?
- I just wanted to emphasize
what, what Jeanne said
which was you guys had
wonderful questions today.
And that you know,
many of these questions are right in line.
The kinds of things that
we try to think about
and try to answer when we're studying.
So keep, stay curious.
Go look at some ants if you want
and just, you know, keep questioning.